des dizaines de milliers de passagers ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier le chaos
survenu à l'aéroport londonien de
gatwick peu avant noël à cause de deux
drones qui survolait le site un accident
sans précédent d'ailleurs faut se faire
obéir de nouvelles règles concernant
l'utilisation des drones qui vont entrer
en vigueur la au cours des prochains
jours je reçois pour en parler benoît
germain des directeurs de l'entreprise
exode ronde bonjour monsieur germain ce
qui s'est passé du côté de gatwick
c'est révélateur d'une situation
mondiale il ya de plus en plus de drones
qui vole la population en fait des deux
drones au canada déjà dépassé le nombre
d'aéronefs standard quel parallèle on
peut faire en ce qui s'est passé ducos
gatwick en fait et les règles en europe
et en sus les nôtres ici
ici on est un petit peu plus sévère en
fait en europe en fait je dirais
principalement de la scion comprend
gatwick
ils ont une règle qui doit on doit
respecter un kilomètre d'un aéroport ici
on est à cinq points six kilomètres si
on doit si on veut on désire se
rapprocher de nerfs ou pas on doit
demander d'autorisation de transport
canada ce qui n'était pas le cas en
anglais on a l'impression des fois qu'on
voit c'est drôle parce qu'avec des
petits en inde et groen impression que c
est en plastique puis que ça va pas
vraiment faire de dommage on se trompe
on se tourne vraiment fait transports
canada en 2013 ont fait d'aider un
rapport en fait on fait des analyses et
ont conclu qu'un drone était deux fois
plus impactante qu'un oiseau pour un
aéronef donc un drone même l'ellipse
hydro qui sont comme pour tout le monde
peuvent transpire c'est une aile
facilement quand on parle de
remboursement il ya des drones
professionnels qui sont utilisés
pour twitter de sa hausse en valais pour
faire la recherche des fois pour aider
d'ailleurs vous c'est dans
ça que vous souhaitez réaliser les
pilotes de devant les pilotes
professionnels
on s'en sert pour quoi au juste et où
que ça peut y allant d'un secteur minier
dans le secteur de l'épandage agricole
dans le secteur exemple pour détecter
des feux de forêt par exemple ou
superviser des feux de forêt ils vont
refaire de la télédétection agricoles
des contres dès que des comptes d'arbres
dans le grand nord il va y avoir des
gens qui vont faire ça pour les les
toitures pour les inspections thermique
une multitude de d'applications
possibles pour les dons de commerciaux
donc ça change énormément de travail de
loin des gens savent évidemment
exactement
bon bien sûr il ya tout le volet
récréatif ouais enfin on peut penser que
peut-être à noël via bien des drones
sont retrouvés sur le savez peut-être
des petits et des moyens par ou des
règles est ce qu'on peut faire voler
notre drôle importe où la réponse est
non en fait malheureusement la réponse
est non en fait au canada mais là ça
fonctionne c'est que si vous faites
voler un autre version dont à noël il ya
deux options qui s'offrent à vous la
première des options il ya des terrains
qui s'appelle les terrains mac donc
c'est modélisme aéronautique associé du
canada qui ont environ mais je vous
dirais 500 terre et au canada et il y en
a une multitude à montréal heureusement
car on a préparé un tableau des règles
donc à respecter peut-être nous dire
lorsqu'on est temps dans un endroit on
peut faire voler notre demande qu'est-ce
qu'il faut suivre comme les deux
facteurs les deux facteurs limitatifs si
vous faites du drone pour le loisir les
deux facteurs les plus dubitatifs son
vous devez vous devez faire voler votre
on a plus de 5.6 kilomètres des héros
pas et vous devez voler dans des ondes
qu'on appelle en fait des zones non
contrôlées et pour les gens qui sont un
peu plus profane par rapport à ces
termes là il ya des applications et des
outils comme ça qui font en sorte que
sont internet c'est très facile à syrte
où la liste est assez longue mais on en
a sorti quelques-uns l'info faire voler
notre au moins à plus de 30 mètres en
fait véhicules de bateaux à plus de 56
kilomètres de l'aéroport à moins de neuf
kilomètres d'une zone de catastrophe pas
nuire bien sûr au travail des équipes
d'urgence par exemple de policiers quand
on dit également
faire voler le jour jamais dans les
nuages toujours dans notre champ de
vision et une altitude maximale de 90 m
on parlait de loin des zones de
catastrophe
c'est pas une bonne idée d'aller filmer
dans ce qui se passe parce qu'on peut
nuire exactement lors d'un feu de soirée
par exemple on aurait nui vraiment
parler conclut 09 vol à basse altitude
dans les feux de forêt puis les gens
sont curieux valais les warsameh vous
intervenir en fait dans le travail d
aider les équipes d'urgence la bon quels
sont les changements annoncés par
transports canada y en a qui s'en
viennent en fait on nous avait promis un
changement pour 2018 et là on nous a dit
que ça allait rentrer rapidement 2019
les principaux changements en fait le
lèche le changement majeur c'est que
aujourd'hui on fait la distinction entre
les votes de loisirs et commerciaux il
aurait pu cette distinction le monde
doit être traitée sur un pied d'égalité
et on a déterminé en fait des zones à
risque et il y avait un nouveau métier
hors nouvelle licence de transport
canada deux pilotes de drones comme les
pilotes d'hélicoptère pilote d'avion et
par opposition ceux qui ne n'ont pas
cette licence vont être forcés de voler
à l'extérieur dans les rues donc ce sont
des licences pour des pilotes
professionnels pouvoir continuer mais il
ya des ondes en fait parce qu'il ya le
plus important c'est de voler dans des
zones qui ça ne sont pas contrôlés et
comme ça je vous disais tantôt il ya des
applications sur internet même sur
iphone android ou est ce que vous allez
voir si sévère vous pouvez vallée du
céou je vous pouvez donc c'est donc ça
facilite la vie ça se trouve facilement
sur internet
d'ailleurs en vous
suggère madame messieurs si vous avez un
drone allez voir sur le site du
gouvernement du canada pour voir les
règles à suivre parce que bon vous a
donné quelques quelques points comme ça
mais selon le poids de notre appareil là
il pourrait avoir des permis qu'il faut
exiger en fait le nouveau cadre
réglementaire au délimiter des zones à
risques puis ils ont dit si vous voulez
aller voler dans des sens saison-là
falloir avoir une licence officielle
sinon ça va être un peu l'équivalent de
si vous voulez vous acheter un bateau
pour aller sur le fleuve vous avez
besoin de vos cartes et au nautic vous
allez devoir passer des cartes
aéronautique drones si on veut mais vous
allez être forcé de rester à l'extérieur
des zones à risque si vous voulez
rentrer dans les zones à risque
transports canada vont renforcer le
niveau de professionnalisme des gens qui
vont aller voler là et avec qui plus est
ils vont ajouter l'obligation de voler
sur des drones conforme qui respecte des
normes de fabrication de conception on
peut s'attendre que des règles s'ajuste
d'année en année c'est déjà prévu en
fait
année après année il vraiment d'un
niveau de professionnalisme de plus en
plus élevé peut atteindre des niveaux de
risque qui sont similaires à ceux qu'on
connaît dans le vert de l'aviation
civile maintenant germain directeur de
l'entreprise exo grand merci beaucoup
merci d'hormones et et on va espérer que
les gens vont voler de façon sécuritaire
d'oxygène